which Hogwarts house would not be in
Gryffindor Ravenclaw Hufflepuff
Slytherin are you are you a Harry Potter
fan not to the extent that I would stick
myself in a one of the houses but if I
but uh I don't give up
um Gryffindor
let's see what I would go for Gryffindor
they're probably saying Hufflepuff let's
see what happens
Hufflepuff 58 how did I know
um it's a good one like it's The
Underdogs I know it's a bit harmless
though isn't it yeah so the traits are
like hard-working yeah nice to a fault
okay and
um kind
and just like good people okay uh I'll
take it but they are known as the
Selfies aren't they I'll take it okay it
could have been worse could it uh